[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
me acompaña en el estudio más Romero
salamar bienvenida volvemos a uganda
para hacer el seguimiento al brote de
bola que actualmente está en transcurso
no en ese país está ocurriendo
actualmente Lamentablemente Buenos días
desde hace ya más de un mes que se
anunció este brote Vamos a repasar las
cifras para hacernos una idea de cómo
está la situación en este momento según
la última actualización del Ministerio
de uganda de hace pues menos de una de
una hora hay 64 casos confirmados de
ébola además de 20 casos probables que
no se han podido confirmar clínicamente
no Qué más hay también 25 víctimas
mortales y además de estas cifras es
importante destacar que ocho de estos
contagios se tratan de personas que no
tenían un contacto previo registrado con
las personas que sí están registradas
como contactos de las personas pues que
están enfermas no algo que es
preocupante explicaba ayer MS porque
sigue preocupando que haya más cadenas
de transmisión y más contagios de los
que sabemos en las comunidades afectadas
el Ministerio de salud Investiga los
ocho casos más recientes ya que los
registros indican que no estaban entre
los contactos rastreados
mar cómo se está manejando la respuesta
a esta brote O sea primero hay el
confinamiento de unas regiones que ya
anunciamos en días anteriores también
grandes campañas de concienciación de
higiene que además es importante
recordar pues uganda no será la primera
vez que está manejando un brote como
este aunque Es verdad que es el mayor en
los últimos años que más los también los
centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades de África los cdc africanos
aseguran que todavía el brote está en
una dimensión manejable que no hace
falta activar más medidas de emergencia
y también la Organización Mundial de la
Salud y el gobierno de uganda ayer
confirmaban a que se ensayará esa vacuna
de la Universidad de Oxford producida
por el ser instituto de India que
anunciábamos también en espacios previos
de salud de esta misma semana no es una
vacuna en estudios de fase 1 contra la
variante Sudán de esta variante de este
brote del ébola una variante que todavía
no tiene tratamientos ni vacunas
confirmadas que funcionen pues para
contenerlo además también se ensayará se
distribuirá en uganda para ensayar una
vacuna hecha para el instituto saban de
Estados Unidos Además este mismo país
norteamericano Estados Unidos envió un
tratamiento experimental de la
farmacéutica Aguila del Rem de sibit que
nos suena además
19 Exacto es una nueva variante de estos
anticuerpos monoclonales especial para
esta variante De nuevo de la variante de
Sudán y que se va a dirigir a los
trabajadores de la salud puede parecer
un poco raro no que se ensayen
medicamentos o vacunas en un brote
actual pero en realidad es una de las
únicas formas una vez se ha demostrado
digamos que la vacuna Es segura No que
que sí provoca una respuesta inmune es
la única forma que tenemos para avanzar
eh saber si realmente previene de los
contagios después Sabiendo si si
previene contra el covid 19 y una
esperanza no una oportunidad mejor eso
que pues no tener no tener algo una
herramienta en la mano para ayudarte
pasamos a otro tema más las muertes de
niños por problemas de riñón después de
tomar un jarabe contra la tos sí es una
noticia verdaderamente Trágica que lleva
desarrollándose en las últimas semanas y
hay digamos dos ramas por un lado
Indonesia el Ministerio de salud ha
asegurado que este año ya se han dado 99
muertes por daños en niños por daños
agudos en el riñón asociados a tomar
estos jarabes contra la tos y contra la
fiebre y por otro lado en gambia también
Investiga un repunte de muertes son 70
víctimas mortales en este caso y en su
caso son jarabes hechos por las
farmacéuticas Maiden farmacéuticas de
India sin embargo el caso de Indonesia
en Indonesia no están disponibles estos
tratamientos entonces ahí pues se genera
un poco de confusión sin embargo si hay
un punto en común y es que en ambos
casos se detectaron niveles excesivos de
proyectil englicol y de dietilenglicol
que son unas sustancias sintéticas que
absorban el agua por ejemplo la primera
sustancia que decíamos se usan
anticongelantes y que es el riñón el
encargado depurarlas si se consume en
altas cantidades se pueden llegar a
formar unos cristales que dañan el riñón
y como vemos pues llegan a provocar la
muerte vamos con lo que me gusta a mí
las buenas noticias y esta vez sobre un
tratamiento contra el cáncer Sí muy
brevemente se ha llegado a un acuerdo
entre la farmacéutica novartis Y pues el
equipo no de la medicina pool un
mecanismo para compartir patentes en
todo el mundo para poder fabricar una
versión genérica del nilotino un
tratamiento que lleva ya 20 años
existiendo contra la deducción pero que
era relativamente caro esto que va a
permitir Pues que se fabrique de forma
genérica mucho más barato precisamente
ayer hablábamos de cómo hacer accesibles
los tratamientos contra el cáncer
definitivamente Esta es una de las
formas para hacerlo no por ejemplo en
Guatemala la patente todavía va a seguir
vigente durante unos años entonces eso
va a ayudar a que este tratamiento unos
tipos de leucemia sean más accesible
para todo el mundo y con esta buena
noticia mar finalizamos salud por el día